>> Laura: IT ISN'T ENOUGH TO
HIGHLIGHT LOCAL BIAS AMONG
SOCIAL MEDIA GIANTS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A WAY TO FIGHT
BACK.
AN ALTERNATIVE.
I THINK IT'S EASY
HERE'S AN INCOMPLETE LIST OF
RECENT STEPS TAKEN.
PERSONALITY ALEX JONES, MILEY
ANNAPOLIS, AND LOWER LOOM ARE
HAVE BEEN PERMANENTLY BANNED BY
TWITTER.
CANDACE OWENS WAS BANNED FOR
SEVEN DAYS BY SAYING WHITES A
PREMISE HE WAS NOT A BIG THREAT
TO AMERICA THAN STALINISM.
MICHELLE MALKIN WAS SUSPENDED
FOR OPPOSING CENSORSHIP.
DAN'S CAMINO, TRUMP SOCIAL MEDIA
DIRECTOR, TEMPORARILY BANNED
AFTER HIS POSTWAR FLAG BY "AN
ALGORITHM."
ONE COMPANY IS STEPPING INTO THE
BREACH.
PARLOR IS A TWITTER LIKE
PLATFORM THAT WAS LAUNCHED LAST
YEAR.
IT'S ALREADY ATTRACTED A NUMBER
OF POWERFUL PEOPLE, INCLUDING
SENATOR MIKE LEE AND TRUMP
MANAGER BRAD PASCAL.
HERE'S THE CEO OF PARLOR.
JOHN, IS THIS GOING TO BE A
TWITTER ALTERNATIVE THAT
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN SEEKING?
>> I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
BEING AN ALTERNATIVE.
I THINK IT SHOULD BE MORE OF A
PLATFORM THAT SOCIAL MEDIA
SHOULD HAVE BEEN WHEN IT WAS
ORIGINATED.
THE REALITY IS THEY ARE MORE
ACTING LIKE PUBLICATIONS RATHER
THAN A COMMUNITY FORUM.
THAT'S GENERALLY WHAT SHOULD BE
CREATED, A COMMUNITY FORUM FOR
PEOPLE TO DISCUSS POLITICS,
WHATEVER THEY'D LIKE.
>> Laura: NO CENSORING.
IF SOMEONE SAYS SOMETHING
INCITING VIOLENCE, YOU WILL
LEAVE IT UP?
>> SEE, ACTUALLY AGAINST THE
LAW.
ANYTHING THAT WE GET INVOLVED
WITH HAS TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
CONSTITUTIONAL VIOLATION, SOME
SORT OF SUPREME COURT PREMISE.
SOMETHING THAT SAYS, HEY, THAT'S
REALLY NOT ALL RIGHT.
THERE HAS TO BE A PREMISE FOR
IT, THOUGH.
WE DO NOT WANT TO GET INTO THE
BUSINESS OF DETERMINING WHAT IS
AND IS NOT ALLOWED TO BE
DISCUSSED.
>> Laura: WHAT'S YOUR PLATFORM
FOR MAKING MONEY HERE?
IS IT, YOU KNOW, USING -- I
LOOKED THROUGH YOUR PRIVACY
STATEMENT.
I ALWAYS DO THAT, BELIEVE IT OR
NOT.
THEY GATHER INFORMATION,
COOKIES, YOU CAN ASK FOR YOUR
CONTACTS TO BE SHARED.
PHOTOS.
>> MOST OF THAT IS BOILERPLATE,
TO BE HONEST.
>> Laura: I READ THE
BOILERPLATE.
I'M A LAWYER.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T READ IT.
THAT'S HOW THEY GET IN TROUBLE.
BUT HOW DO YOU MAKE MONEY ON
THIS.
DO YOU MAKE MONEY BY
PARTNERSHIPS, THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU GATHER?
'S VEHICLE RIGHT NOW, WE ARE
NEVER GOING TO BE SELLING ANY
INFORMATION, SO THAT'S NOT
REALLY IN OUR BUSINESS MODEL.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS RECREATE
WHAT MARKETS SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN
A WAY WHERE WE ARE NOT TARGETING
PEOPLE, USING THEIR INFORMATION.
WE WANT TO PROVIDE THEM WITH AN
OLD-SCHOOL APPROACH TO
ADVERTISING, AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'LL EVENTUALLY BE DOING.
AS WELL AS INFLUENCER MARKETING.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT
NOW, INFLUENCERS CAN CONVEY THE
MESSAGE BETTER THAN INDIVIDUALS.
>> Laura: SO SOMEONE WHO HAS A
BIG MEDIA FOLLOWING, JUST LIKE
THEY HAVE AN INSTAGRAM OR YOU
MAKE MONEY ON INSTAGRAM OR
YOUTUBE, YOU CAN MAKE MONEY MAY
BE -- IS IT PARLOR OR --
>> VEHICLE USED TO BE PAR
>> JUST CALL IT PARLOR.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Laura: GOOD.
I THINK THAT USED TO BE SMART.
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO SEE
WHERE THIS GOES BUT I THINK
MICHELLE MALKIN AND OTHERS ARE
FASCINATED VIA I MIGHT SIGN UP
LATER IN THE NIGHT.
>> THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE CENSORED AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT TO JOIN ME IN UNITY WITHOUT